hey reg how are you I am so glad that
young man in New Zealand because look I
am so I'm glad the podcasts have gone
global obviously but in New Zealand
where we are we are all big wow you're
all B yeah
is there cheating in basketball we were
talking about the Patriots we've been
talking about the Astros the people
cheating basketball here's my thing now
don't doesn't every team do what the
Patriots are doing I'm not giving them
any license but are they the only ones
getting caught all the time like like
the Astros I thought like growing up in
Little League
didn't the oppose our our you know
manager always looked at their manager
to see what their signs were to see if
they could you know figure them out it
isn't that what you're supposed to be
doing or no well you do have it feels
like every every team has one guy who
tries to decipher signals but if you're
using you know techni modern technology
iPhones you're using cameras in center
field like then that's different because
that's espionage you know the other part
is just that's part of baseball you know
what the Patriots are doing maybe they
are the only ones getting caught but I
didn't know if anybody cheats in
basketball is there a way to cheat in
basketball I don't know if there's a way
to cheat I really don't because what you
go over in your shoot arounds everyone
runs the same place
they're just disguised differently it's
either high screen or old side screen
and roll or step back threes everyone's
running the same place so I'm not quite
sure there's a way to to videotape or or
cheat that way but if this is true from
what I read if the eight minutes of
videotape was being shown on the coaches
and signals again I know Belichick is
going to come out and say
I didn't direct anyone to do it someone
in your organization was directed to do
this this coming from a Colts fan Reggie
Miller just so everybody knows you're
still not over that no I'm not and I'm
sure there's a lot of teams that are in
the Super Bowl that are not over this
videotaping thing but my thing with this
reg with the whole deflate gate is each
you know your quarterback shouldn't be
able to have the football to his liking
and the same with the opposing
quarterback I couldn't care less I'm
curious if you ever played with a
basketball that you didn't like but
let's say you're playing against the
Lakers and magic wanted that ball or the
Celtics and Larry Bird wanted that ball
did you ever have a basketball I would
have changed the ball absolutely yeah
but you couldn't do it if you're playing
on their home court can you most of the
time the road team the road team gets to
choose the ball Oh most of the time and
so this is what would happen mark and I
usually mark Montana card right mark
Jackson would go to the you know the
officials habit and both captains are up
there so market I would be up there and
the opposing cap you'll say it's Larry
Bird and you know Dennis John Orr Kevin
McHale and you know we're in the garden
and bird says this is the ball we want
to use I would turn to mark and you know
we would have a signal and he would be
like no we need another ball and so on
the road the road team I would say
generally gets to choose the ball
because obviously for what you're saying
the home team the homers no the balls
right yeah so you would change the ball
the home team or the row team usually
gets to choose the basketball I'm not
gonna let Larry legend use the ball that
he wants to use but wouldn't you do that
with every game if you were on the road
and you went into somebody's arena and
they said this is the ball we're using
you automatically go absolutely change
absolutely change and you would hope and
then this is the trick we used to do at
home the balls we wanted to you
right we would take the ones that we did
want you to say this is the ball we're
using know one of the other things we
were doing so they feel a bit about this
one you're like okay we'll go with that
one knowing that because we'd put like
tiny X's okay this is a form of Chi me
tiny X's on the side of the ball the
ones that were good yeah and then the
ones that were bad would put an O so we
would have the O's out there saying this
is a ball we want and we want to use
knowing that they're going to change it
and we would find the X's and use those
balls during the game round it goes up
in the air and you shoot it okay come on
but how do you know when you have a bad
basketball too much air you never want
to have too much air okay
in a basketball point guards are like I
don't know they're like air savants when
it comes to that so you never want to
have too much air in a basketball
especially it falls off your hands when
you're dribbling so point guards are
usually get it at recognizing that
speaking of Mark Jackson names being
thrown around for the Knicks a coaching
job I mean you love Mark Jackson do you
want to see him put through this
purgatory of coaching the Knicks it
would pay me he is the Godfather to my
son it would pain for me to go for him
to go through this but I think you would
be the shot that the Knicks need to have
a hometown guy a guy who played for the
organization Waunakee of the year there
but you and I know mark he's been in
line for this for one of the last like
eight years right as if his name always
been mentioned for the next that he
never gets it so maybe they'll get it
right this time
but I think the Knicks need something
because what what has been out there for
the last 15 years has been a joke they
need a new front office though reg you
need an owner who stays out of it you
need a new front office who will allow
who will get a good coach and they work
in unison because right now that is a
toxic place no free agent wants to go
there
and it will never happen never happen
because the owner will never stay out of
it
and he keeps enabling the front office
did you know at some point in time it
can't always be about the coach I mean
hi when you come out and your statement
is you didn't get Kyrie you didn't get
Katie you didn't get Kawhi but your
statement is we got who we wanted which
was more powerful words Bobby Portis
really Taj Gibson I love hard worker
really Julius Randle really that's
really who you guys wanted to get that
can't be your statement you get to see
Carmelo there yeah with the Portland uh
Nuggets game there okay how surprised
are you well it's coming back to Denver
I'm excited for him you know I know he's
played you know his initial games were
great they've kind of fallen off a
little bit in terms of winning ball
games so it'll be good to see him I mean
I was happy for him I I'm just surprised
it took this long dan really but that
seems a lot of teams now but do you
think LeBron looks at this and says you
know what maybe maybe we should have
brought Carmelo in no no because I think
what it was a perfect fit for Melo in
Portland because that office was very
stagnant it was a always between
McCollum and Lillard they had the
injuries so it was a perfect fit because
they needed instant office and that's
what Melo brings the Lakers they're
playing both ends of the floor
I mean as great as they're playing
offensively and the win streak which was
just busted by the way
defensively they're at the top half and
that's not mellows game knows all about
the office not that he would have tried
but I'll think it was been as good a fit
as the Blazers as it would have been for
the Lakers I agree yeah and you know
who's gotten lost in all of this and not
that he's asking for recognition is
Frank Vogel
I think Vogel and I said at the time
there was no drama low-key guy bringing
in there even though you tried to you
know force in Jason Kidd as well Vogel
has done a very good job quietly with
this team and and they are very good at
both ends of the floor
can I bring something out cuz you and I
had a conversation a couple weeks ago
and you you kind of went at me without
anthony davis not being a top 10 player
oh okay well change your tune a little
bit have you changed your tune a little
bit okay you only have to ask me once
yes okay
the Greek freak is one right sure okay
James Harden okay do I put Luca Don
chicken over Anthony thing so you're
just teetering on the the you know
inside of the top five here Kawhi
Leonard now I got Anthony Davis on the
outside so now he's sixth Kawai
apologist but it's killing me that you
know he's not playing back their backs
so that may take him out of the top five
right because he doesn't play every game
okay I know what I'm gonna get come
April May and June I don't know what I'm
getting with Anthony Davis though I I
was on the bandwagon before most people
were with Anthony Davis and I have the
tape here to say that he'll have the
breakout year which he did when he was
in New Orleans so I've already been on
his bandwagon I said and he's every bit
the talent that the Greek freak is he's
a different gave me much evany Davis
being top five he's gonna and what I
said he's gonna take votes away from
LeBron that's why I LeBron probably will
not win in VP bizarro but they're gonna
split votes okay that's a top five
towers I'd love to be healthy you're
talking about Kawhi
not in the top five cuz he doesn't play
enough Anthony Davis has not played
enough I want to see him be healthy if
he's healthy play 70 games I hope he
wins offensive and you know defensive
MVP how's that huh how's that they're
not okay I just like how you cooled a
little bit to that whole conversation so
thank you I'm glad you've come full
circle with me he's one of the top five
players in LA in the state of California
he's one of the top five players nice I
think Anthony Davis is more than lived
up to the promise there I just want him
to be healthy for an entire season and
that's something even right now he's not
healthy still planning he's playing
going 70 plus games and the numbers he's
doing at both ends yes I think he has a
shot to be Defensive Player of the Year
and he'll be a finalist for the MVP
along with LeBron they won't win it
because they're gonna take votes away I
think it's Yanis is to lose again but if
you do the Lakers look at load
management here for Anthony Davis though
reg at some point in time they're going
to have to but I think I really think
they want to get that number one seed in
the West I think that they want
everything to run through them come
playoff time I think that's what's
important to them so I think they're
gonna is we're going to come down to
that that March schedule you know if
they're four or five games ahead I think
their start to pick and choose spots
when to rest both of those guys LeBron -
they need to the load management on
LeBron as well now LeBron wants to make
a statement his statement is I don't
need load management yeah but look you
got to be smarter than that
I agree Gordon like regular season or
the playoffs he's got to be fresh come
playoff time - I agree absolutely when
you were in New Orleans I know that you
brought it up that you thought that
jaian was going to be coming back he
gave sort of a timeframe here no no
again I don't let me clarify what I said
I don't think we'll see him this
calendar year when in 2020 will we see
him
I'm thinking more after the all-star
break now David Griffin in them they
swear he'll be back sooner than that Wow
he is not even on the court yet so it's
gonna take him look he's a big dude I
got a chance to speak with him in the
locker room that's a big dude he's a
wide dude he's not as don't miss people
think I'm taller than him yes I'm taller
than him
why does in when Sir Charles
Philadelphia wide why do but do you
think they wanted do you think that that
this is just this is more strategic that
we're gonna I think it is I really do I
think their message is he's coming back
he's coming back to keep interest for
New Orleans they have a ton of national
games they don't want to be flexed she's
coming back coming back so the network's
keep coming there but I I would look huh
I could be I hope I'm wrong I want him
to be on the court in January I just
don't think he's coming back anytime
soon and they're gonna take their time
which they should because he's
generational type player and they're
gonna take their time and bring him back
I also wanted to bring this up this'll
sound so random but this guy the reason
why this guy I love what he's done
because he works hard and he didn't get
to the the NBA and then stop Andre
Drummond is averaging 17 and 17 three
years ago he's shooting 38% from the
free-throw line he's up to 64% now I
know that he's not gonna be featured
they're not people don't go out of their
way to watch Andre Drummond but he's a
full-time legitimate star in the NBA and
in terms of what people talk about the
best centers in the game you go with
Yogesh obviously Joel embiid he always
gets overlooked even people wanna throw
any Davis which to me I think after
Davis is more of a powerful current any
towns are karl-anthony towns people
forget about Drummond is because he
plays in Detroit and
usually they're teetering around the
eight nine ten spot and they get off to
slow starts which the Pistons have done
but you talk about a walking
double-double I mean I think he leads
all big men in 2020 games this year yeah
he's been really impressive what
happened to Blake Griffin probably dude
look he's always had knee problems
you talk about a guy that has always
been injured right has the talents but
always been injured I will say this
I'll give Lake a lot of credit because
he was playing on one knee during the
playoffs last year you know and look
phenomenal but but he kind of did I
guess Detroit makes you disappear
because I it does you know you're what
the Clippers you're in LA you know
you're yes then you're in Detroit by the
way Ben Simmons 2 for 4 from three-point
range
all right look I am gonna put my I'm
gonna nominate him for the three-point
contest this year I really AM why not
he's shooting 50% why not wait did he
ever take you up on that offer that you
said you would help him in the arm super
called he never called him maybe that's
a good thing
oh wait wait what Paulie we heard he
called ray oh he called Ray Allen he
wanted have a really good
Wow Paulie that's a walk off sorry
that's a walk off and that's
mean-spirited you shouldn't be doing
that to Reggie it's all right yeah okay
I'm not quite sure ray would have called
him back I would at least called him
back Wow yeah he kept his form you could
have you could have helped you I don't
know why he wouldn't have taken you up
on that offer
I don't know why I wouldn't be crazy not
my number are still the same I know feel
the same I know somebody out there who's
with Ben Simmons should should get a
hold of Reggie and and the fact that he
will give you he'll put you in the lab
and you know you'll you'll help him
there we're not going to be doing any
Instagram videos making it look cute and
all that we're going back to old Hoosier
type you know we're gonna run your legs
get your legs tired first and then start
to shoot Larry Bird turns 63 this week
oh my guy my idol Larry Lancer my game
you know getting Larry legend still he
could still shoot yeah yeah who is the
oldest best shooter you've ever been
around Craig Hodges
yeah but Hodges isn't that old is he oh
I am but there has to be Birds a better
shooter than Hodges hidden II know I
would go with Hodges okay give me some
energy sorry but I think three I would
say bird is probably the best who would
be else who else would be up there in
their 60s Wow I'm trying to think Dale
Ellis you're not sexy
oh you're doing this 50 all right I got
to find somebody he's 59 reg Ellis is 59
yeah Wow that's borderline I'm trying to
think who would be the oldest best
shooter Larry legend maybe maybe a 50 to
60 years of age three-point shooting
contest
so you would have Chris Mullin yeah
Craig Hodges DLLs myself ah
Dell curry okay right there yeah Dell
curry you guys would run out of energy
though I think I tune in for it I'd tune
in for that
you know the slam dunk contest I'm all
good for all-star weekend reg will be on
the call with Kevin Harlan and Kristen
Ledlow that'll be 10:30 Eastern on
Thursday night Blazers and the Nuggets
thanks reg we'll talk to you soon
top 5 LA players LeBron 80 qui Paul
George and this is going to shock you
Ronnie jr. better than Dwyane Wade son
yes okay Ronny does LeBron play this
brawny and LeBron play together oh
absolutely
I hope I can still plays record I hope I
really do but absolutely they're playing
one-on-one absolutely no together in the
NBA
oh no that won't happen oh I think it
will I think it will he's a freshman at
C Erica I think so by then we'll be done
with the one and done comes no no that's
alright here's three more years no all
right I'm gonna take the over I'm gonna
take you know you're going with the King
Griffey yeah you hear that yeah yeah I'm
following what that be though all right
I gotta go love you thank you buddy
that's Reggie Miller for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR
five or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]